hi
i'm victor kolobov and today i'll talk
to you about the download rate of
promoting secretary and this is a joint
one with infinite firstly yuvali shai
and mary woods
so consider the following application of
fully revolted encryption suppose that
alice
has some secret input x and she wants to
delegate the computation of some
function f on her input to selma
such that then bob will be able to learn
the value of f of x
so the way she can do it she can just
encrypt
her secret
using the folio morphic encryption have
the server perform the computation on
the ciphertext and then send it to bob
who can decrypt it
using the secret key
now obviously
for this
scenario we want
the ciphertext to hide alice's input
from the server
and also for the problem to be
non-trivial we want some sort of
compactness in the sense that the
decryption function
should be
a much simpler
than the function description
and this is because otherwise the server
could just send the encryption of x to
bob together with a description of f
now hsn can be viewed
as a distributed variant of fha where
instead of encrypting the input we
secret sharing
between a group of servers
and
here we'll say that the hss
is
satisfies or has the privacy if any
collusion of
of size t or less
learns nothing about the secret input
now
the downside of hss compared to fha is
that we need to assume that there are
multiple non-polluting servers but for
a many applications this is not an issue
and as a plus we get
good efficiency features such as
hss
commonly has additive reconstruction
which is uh
implies the reconstruction algorithm is
very simple it just adds together all
the output charts and also
you don't need to worry about public and
secret keys
in addition hss unlike fhe can exist
with information theoretic security
for simple functions f
now
consider the following scenario
of computation on sequential data
suppose we have clients and servers and
the clients upload
their data in a secret manner
in a secret shared manner to the servers
and in return they get some statistical
information which depends on all of the
inputs
in addition consider another
scenario
where
there is some database d of records of
length l bits
which is replicated among
a group of servers and the client wants
to secretly recover
the record di
and
this is known as private information
and
an example of this could be a
privately viewing
movies
and the private information retrieval
can also be cast in the hss framework if
we view the database as the truth table
of some function
now
in both of these scenarios
either the first one uh where we can
have many
statistical estimates but we want to
compute all the
second scenario well
we can view each bit of the output as a
separate function
so in both of these scenarios we can
have
many
possible computations
so in general in this work
our motivation is large scale
computation on signature inputs
and the primary goal of this work is to
try and minimize the total download cost
for the client
so as an example consider an hss for the
product of two field elements
which can be done using chameleon
signature so suppose we have two clients
with inputs a and b
and three servers
the clients can use shamir signature
uh between the servers
and this is done by just having each
client choose a random line
whose in intersection with the y axis is
its input
and send the server
one evaluation point of that line
then to proceed with the computation the
servers can just locally multiply their
shells so now
the
servers hold
evaluation points of the parabola whose
intersection with the y-axis is a times
b
and by multiplying with the
by the appropriate lagrange multipliers
and adding all the outputs together
we can recover the product of
a and b
and
note that
this scheme has a download rate of one
third and in general for so-called
additive hss
which means that the agencies has an
additive reconstruction
uh the rate we get is one over the
number of servers
so then this begs the question can we do
better if we want to perform
if we're allowed to perform multiple
products so a1 times b1 a2 times b2 and
so forth
and the answer to that is yes
uh we can do that with the so-called
benchmark scheme
which approaches rate one half as the
number of servers goes to infinity
and the way this works is that now each
client
chooses a random parabola
which passes at two points corresponding
to
the client's inputs and the product of
these two parabolas is a degree for a
polynomial
so we need five servers to be able to
recover this degree for polynomial and
learn our
products
but then
as previously mentioned this only
approaches rate half
and
the question still remains whether we
can approach rate one as the number of
server
number of servers increases
so moving on to our results first in the
first part of our results we showed that
a
a
construction for an optimal download
linear hss for low degree polynomials
so here optimal download means that we
have both a positive and negative
result
and linear hss just means that both the
shared reconstruction algorithms are
linear functions and indeed
we show that for t private k sum over
hss
and for degrading polynomials the best
possible rate is 1 minus dt over k
and as an application
we show we construct the p private case
server pilo and protocol
for n size databases such that the
upload cost is n to the one over d
and the download rate is one minus dt
over k
now compare this to the optimal
known rate for pr for pi where the
upload cost now is linear
in the database size
then the optimal node rate is 1 minus t
over k divided by 1 minus q over k to
the power of n the database size
and just to give you a few data points
even for a database of size 10
this
difference in rate is not significant
and
if instead we want to improve the upload
cost of the payer scheme then
in the following example the rate drops
from
0.6 sorry from 0.8 to 0.6
but
on the flip side
we get savings in the upload cost by two
orders of magnitude
now uh
to
the second part of our results we obtain
a
rate amplification technique for
additive hss
which can be done in a black box manner
so a first variant of this result
uh in the first variant of this result
we showed that a fully private k2c
server additive hss
for some function class f
can be converted to a t private k server
hss
for l independent evaluations of that
function class with rate 1 minus t over
k
and
this is the best we can do
using the blackbox approach because uh
simple information genetic arguments
shows
that for some function classes
for example those when there is a
function which attains
all possible y values
then this is the best rate possible
and of course this does not contradict
the pi result
the pi optimal rate results from before
because there we can have record sizes
which are significantly longer than the
database size
and as a combinary we obtain high rate
hss
a scheme for circuits from nwe
now moving on to a second variant of
this black box approach we show how to
convert a one five and two several
additive edges from some function class
to a one prime at k server ranges
we've read one minus one over k this is
somewhat surprising
because
here
it's sufficient
to start from a 1.2 server hss
to obtain a an hss scheme with optimal
rate
and as a corollary we obtained particle
high rate kr from one wave functions
and they compare this is compared to
previous high repair constructions from
stronger
assumptions such as lwe or dbh
of course in these constructions we only
require
one server but the downside is that the
record length l needs to go like a
polynomial in the security parameter
while
our result
gives a sort of a different flavor of
highlight area in that
the record length can be independent of
the security parameter it just depends
on the number of syllables
as a second corollary we get high rate
hss for a bunch of programs from ddh or
dcr
and moving on to a third variant of this
black box approach we show how to start
from some
additive hss
and convert it to an hss with the same
amount of privacy
and k servers such that the rate is 1
minus 1 over theta of square root of k
and the main motivation here
is to obtain a pir protocol for and size
databases where the upload cost is sub
polynomial
and since this
pi constructions are
don't follow from hss for long
polynomials here we opted to use the
black box approach to obtain a
construction with a
construction for pr where the
approaches one
and finally moving on to our third
part of our results
we
show how to
utilize nonlinearity to amplify the rate
of hss
so in the previous two parts
we had to increase the number of servers
to increase the download rate
of our hss scheme and this begs the
question whether we can do we can
somehow increase the rate without
increasing the number of servers
and the main observation here is that
the output shells of an hss
are non-uniform and correlated
so
one can draw inspiration from the
distributed source coding
literature
unfortunately uh
syntactically we cannot apply the
classical slapping world coding
result
because the servers don't know the
distribution of the output charts
due to the privacy requirement of hss
and but nevertheless we obtain a
slapping wealth style result for hss
which gives us a non-linear er
electricity linear reconstruction and
a negligible error probability
and applying it to a one pilot cell one
five and three server hss for the end of
two bits
we can obtain a rate which is strictly
higher than one third and
an hss4 end is useful for applications
such as private set intersection
finally as a bonus feature uh
we obtained a
we showed that this hss for end
exhibits symmetric privacy
and this is without needing to share uh
to randomize the output shares
now here symmetric privacy means that
the output shells reveal only f of x and
nothing else
and
the usual way to obtain symmetric
privacy
uh when considering h6 games is just to
randomize the output shares for example
by adding a fresh sharing of zero to the
output charts but this of course
destroys any hope of
allowing some sort of combustion and
here we show that this hss we consider
somehow enjoys the best of both worlds
in that it can both be compressed and it
satisfies symmetric privacy
now
in the rest of the talk i'll just
discuss
some ideas regarding the download rate
of agencies for low degree polynomials
so consider the problem of hss for l
concatenation
so here we have a
l users and each user has some data x i
which is signatures among the summers
and the tasks
that we want to
perform is to have the output client
recover all the inputs
given all the output shares of course
we want each server to learn
if we consider key privacy we want the
servers to
articulation of the servers to not learn
anything about the inputs
and one
a central tool for this construction is
the so-called t-pilot case server cnf
secret sharing
so this secret sharing is done as
follows
suppose we additively share some secret
and the number of additive shares
corresponds to the number of t-sized
subsets of the indices 1 to k where case
the number of servers
and then
each server j receives all the shares
associated with sets which don't contain
its index j
this is an example of a linear
secretion scheme
and
but
of course this has bad information rate
in that
to just
share one secret each server needs to
receive roughly k2
field elements
nevertheless uh
cnf secret sharing is useful for us due
to its so-called universality
and what do i mean by that
i mean the following theory and my
camera number that is
2005
where they show that any t private cnf
sharing of x can be locally converted
to
a
t private sharing of x over any linear
secret sharing scheme
and in this work we
make a simple extension to this theorem
by
showing that
any individual t private senate sharing
of l secrets can be locally converted to
a joint to any joint
t private linear multi-signature scheme
of all the secrets
and note that this already implies hss
for concatenation
given that we find a linear multi
signaturing with good rate
so this
becomes uh our goal and indeed
uh there is a theorem by gamma and manga
from 2010
will they construct a linear
multi-secret sharing scheme over a field
f
where each share is a single element of
the field with k servers and secret t
privacy and information like l of okay
they show that this exists if only if
there is a linear code with parity
matrix h
so that
this code has distance at least t plus
one
and the rate at least l over k
and
as a
as an extension
we show an extension of this
where each shell is a vector
over
f of size b
and using this
we can show
the following theorem which says that
there is a t private k server linear
which is for l concatenation with output
shares over f of b and download rate l
over k
b
here linear means
that the shallow construction algorithms
are linear
we showed that such an hss exists if and
only if there is an f linear code
uh over f b to the k with distance at
least t plus one and rate at least l a
over k b
and for the if direction of this theorem
uh
the
output they saw in the input shells of
the hss are cnf input shells
and
instantiating this theorem with
petroville we showed that there is uh
it implies there is a t private case
someone linear registers for l
concatenation
uh with output just over uh the field f
and downward rate y minus t over k
of course here we need to assume that
the field size is at least
the size of the number of cells
now
this was hss for concatenation and
the question is how can we construct so
hsn for concatenation in particular
can be shown to imply agencies for
degree one polynomials
and now this begs the question
uh how to construct matrices for a
degree d polynomials where d is greater
than one
and the main observation here is that
syrup sharing is multiplicative
so it means that you can locally convert
t private cnf sharings of these secrets
to a td private signal sharing of the
product
so in the following example
we convert
two private sharings of a b and c to a
sixth private sharing of the product
and as a conclusion it implies there is
a t private case of hss for degree d
polynomials with c and f input shells
and download red mine minus dt over k
this is by just combining the
multiplicativity
the multiplicative property of cnf
sharing
with a hss for concatenation
now
the downside of using cnf is that the
input shell size
is large
and
one possible way to mitigate this is to
try and use shamir's signature instead
where each
shell is just a single field element
and indeed it is also well known that
shamir secret sharing is multiplicative
so
so we only need to be able to construct
an hss for concatenation
for chameleon's secret challenge
and then
this leads us to the problem of finding
a linear multi-secret challenge with
good rate to which we can convert our
shamir shells too
and one idea here is to use regenerating
grid soluble codes which
are essentially
chameleon are equivalent to shamil's
secretary
so here
we have a
code word
and one node
is missing and we want to recover
the value of this node you by
downloading as little information as
possible
from all the other nodes
uh however unfortunately
we cannot use off-the-shelf regenerating
codes
and no discussion on that in the paper
but essentially it follows because the
regenerative codes
need to recover
all possible nodes and we only care
about
some specific nodes which hold our
secrets
but nevertheless we can adapt ideas from
the regenerating codes literature and as
a result we get a construction which is
simpler than
the regenerating codes construction
so
in conclusion we get a t private k
server hss for degree d polynomials with
shamir input charts and download rate
which is one minus dt over k
and comparing
this scheme to
the cnf based one obviously shamir has
better input shaft size by factor of
roughly k choose t
on the upside c f is simpler and
also we show in the paper that cnf
exists for more parameter regimes
and
this is all for my talk so thank you